[Music]
hallo YouTube Ches Lois and her friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
27th episode of my chest trap series in
this episode I'm going to show you one
very interesting and high profile trap
against scotch gambit from the black
perspective the opening arises after the
following model E 4 E Phi Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d4 he kept his d4 and now
white can beat upon with Bishop to c4
there are various ways you can reach to
this position and here in my past I have
created my own replica with black where
I have recommended the move Bishop to c5
which is a nice solid way to play
against watch gambit however in this
video we are going to concentrate on one
of the trap e line starting with the
Hungarian defense Bishop to e7 now White
has a choice whether he take on d4 and
enter into the Hungarian defense main
line or to play proper scores gambit
move and that is c3
so white has created the foss trap that
black cannot touch the c3 pawn for
example if you become greedy and capture
on c3 then that comes Queen to defy haha
and there is no good way to defend on f7
except black has to play this move
Knight to f6
well guess what this is the line which I
am going to recommend in this video
because here white has the obvious
choice Bishop captures at six
not only removing the defender of
Epsilon but black cannot even touch this
bishop as Quinn to f7 leads to the
checkmate
objectively speaking there is only one
defense for black here and that is
castle on the Kings side
afterwards as in white is a clear piece
up well of course that's right but if
you carefully look at this position
there are some threats from the black
camp for example right now black is
threatening the move C captures b2 and
also G captures at six regaining the
piece back so accordingly White has two
popular choice one of them leads to the
trap and the second one even if you open
it doesn't fall for the trap the
resulting position are quite playable
from the black camp before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find
out which move you are going to choose
from the white perspective
well congratulations if you find this
move Bishop to see one because it
straightaway leads to the trophy
territory yes indeed and at first sight
this looks so obvious right because
white is protecting every single [ __ ]
and coming out a healthy piece up but in
chess
sometimes perception can be deceptive
and now in fact it is black who is in
charge of the game
the chemo in this position is not to be
for threatening to squares and white
cannot defend both of them Queen to d1
has most of only try from this position
but after this black will continue with
c2 once again hitting two piece and
after Quint we to pawn captures Knight
rook kept his b1 after the whole
sequence suddenly black emerge with upon
advantage isn't that amazing
well the story doesn't end here in this
position black has a lethal reply which
in fact give him the instant winning
advantage and that is ah ha ha ha so now
black is attacking the bishop and
accordingly white has three choices the
first move he captures defy is a pretty
bad one the simple reason is after
Bishop to fi the truck on the beavin is
a corner
so that's not a good choice for the
right what happens if you continue with
pressure captures defy well more or less
same story here black is going to
capture this bishop and after pawn takes
black has this little check Bishop to b4
which in fact force white King to go
into the f1 square as if he continued
with Bishop to b2 then there comes Roop
th attacking the Queen and forcing white
to give up a piece after Knight to e5
Fisher kept his d2 King captures d2 and
Queen to defy white is going to lose a
piece and his King is going to stuck in
the center for all the assault
even if here white continue with King to
have fun he is thought out of the wound
his after Bishop to a fire attacking the
rook rook to even and now simple move
Queen captures defy and once again black
emerged with an extra pawn and this time
White King is completely misplaced
you
last but not least what happens if you
opponent continue with III
counter-attacking unite here the
sequence is pretty much false you will
take the bishop white will capture unite
now comes Bishop to b4 check Bishop to
d2 Bishop captures v2 and it doesn't
matter however white recaptured let's
say to avoid the Queen exchange if I
take with denied but then after blacks
next reply B Phi this time around black
is a to healthy pawn up and white has
hardly any compensation for it
so this is one of the wonderful trap
exists against scotch can beat in fact
in the online database there are more
than 100 games played from this position
where many below 2000 rated opponent
fall into each and lost the game very
quickly so my recommendation is you
should definitely try in a quick game
format such as rapid or the Blitz game
before I leave I like to point out that
even if you opponent find the move
Bishop kept his g7 black is not in a
trouble as after King captures g7 it
looks like black king is somewhat open
and after Knight to c3 White has some
initiative but this is just an illusion
as after the moon d6
all black want is to move King to h8 and
Bishop to f6 and because black has a
dark square bishop his King is always
going to safe and don't forget black has
the bishop pair which is longer one give
wide some nasty problems
now to illustrate my point I like to
show you my game against a 1988 opponent
where he continued with some logical
moves and still find himself at the
trouble line
at this point he continued with castle
on the Kings side
I played Bishop to have six and now
obvious move Queen to h5 so putting the
Queen sneers to my open King but as I
mentioned there is no danger in the
black cam due to the dark square Bishop
presence and I calmly continue with
Bishop 26 attacking on c4 my opponent
thought that he will open up making more
with Bishop captures e6 pawn captures he
sinks and now rook to d1 threatening
ePHI but i defuse all the threat with
Quinn to e8 counter attacking white
cream he give me the check and I was
more than happy as it helps me to what I
want to do namely King create my
opponent continue with rook after even
so you can see all this moves are very
natural white has some impressive rooks
sitting on the center of the ball but
after all what is the threat I don't see
any threat from the white camp in fact
now as the G file is open it is only
black who is getting advantage and
rightly so I continue with rook to g8
attacking the Queen Queen to s3 and now
simple move Queen to have seven I just
want to involve my last rook which is
sitting in the corner into the game and
after that white will certainly feel the
heat
okay my opponent continued it rook to d3
so his idea is to involve that rook on
the Kings side no matter I continue with
rook to f8 and now Knight to h4 happen
on the board
well so far white plays very logical and
pretty good except there is a huge
problem in the white game which I
exploited it so before I move on the
last time I want you to pause this video
and find out a response which completely
cube black upper hand
well I hope you find this decisive blow
boom ahahaha so suddenly black is a
piece up here I think my opponent was in
time trouble and he captured this piece
without thinking but then comes the
instant resignation after blacks
dazzling reply yup you guessed it rook
to G for a deflection move of the Queen
so that either white has to give up the
Queen or getting horrendous checkmated
by black pieces
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this amazing counter trap against
Scott gambit which you definitely want
to try in your own game for a great
surprise value you never know you can
beat a hiring player within few moves
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care